in addition to welcoming back most of
the familiar faces of the series the new
season of stranger things will introduce
a few newcomers from an intriguing life
guard to an ambitious politician but
even if they're new to Hawkins some of
these actors just might look familiar
there's no doubt that Carey Elvis's
credentials precede his arrival as mayor
Larry Klein in stranger thanks 3 but
what's hard to pinpoint is exactly which
role he's most famous for fantasy fans
probably know him best as the romantic
swordsman Wesley in The Princess Bride
or perhaps the title role in Robin Hood
Men in Tights for horror fans though
it's more likely that it's turns as Lord
Arthur Holmwood and Bram Stoker's
Dracula or dr. Lawrence Gordon and saw
left the biggest marks meanwhile others
might remember elvis Maura's antagonist
Russ wheeler in Days of Thunder or is a
cocky tornado scientist at twister he
may even be familiar to TV fans for his
appearances in series like the x-files
or sight to name a few no matter what
he's best known for he definitely comes
into stranger things as the most veteran
newcomer of the bunch things are just
starting to heat up from Maya Hawkes
career as she joins stranger things as
the ice cream slinging Robin but she's
been a part of show business her entire
life she's the oldest child of Ethan
Hawke and uma Thurman and was born
shortly after her folks mats on the set
of 1997's Gattaca she was raised away
from the limelight but even at a young
age she still douve right into local
theatrical productions and is now
following in her parents footsteps by
pursuing an acting career Hawke made her
on-screen debut in the PBS miniseries
adaptation of Little Women as Jo March
who refuses to conform to the gender
expectations of her era soon after she
appeared in the indie thriller lady
world her post stranger things resume is
already set to make her even more
recognizable the buzziest of our
upcoming projects is probably Quentin
Tarantino's Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood like Maya Hawke Jake Busey is
an heir to a Hollywood legacy who bears
a striking resemblance to his famous
parents he's the son of the inimitable
Gary Busey man has the same white blond
hair and toothy grin as his father in
addition to their similar appearances a
look at his filmography reveals that
Busey also seems to share his dad's
penchant for action-oriented movies and
TV shows
the younger Busey's career began in 1978
when he appeared alongside his father in
the film straight time his credits
really started to build up in the 90s
and the likes of contact and Starship
Troopers more recently he showed up in
2018 s the predator and has
guest-starred on shows like Marvel's
agents of shield ultimately it was his
turn as a psychotic serial killer in
1996 as the frighteners that got the
attention of the duffer brothers and
inspired them to write the role of Bruce
a newspaper journalist with loose morals
and a sick sense of humor
Oh Patricia watch before becoming new
lifeguard Heather and stranger thanks
three Francesca reality had already made
a name for herself on another Netflix
original in the sitcom haters back off
she starred as Emily the very normal
sister of the very abnormal Miranda
sings what is a bag of salami Emily you
know what a bag of salami is only done
we all know what it begger salami is
apart from that series and a guest spot
in a 2016 episode of Blue Bloods reality
still very much an actress who's in the
midst of breaking through like many up
and comers she's been steadily
establishing a real with appearances in
short films with names like the Furies
of war goodbye charm city and cabin she
could also be seen sharing the screen
with stranger things co-starred Natalya
Dyer in the 2019 teen drama yes Scott
yes she might be new to the Bisma
Caroline Arup igloo is quickly rising
through the ranks of TV stars ahead of
her appearance as Winnie and stranger
things 3 she got her start with bit
roles on shows like Atlanta and films
like hot summer nights
she later nabbed a recurring role as lab
tech noni Turner on the resident Arup
igloo also appeared in one episode of
The Walking Dead's ninth season a zombie
apocalypse survival Rose after stranger
things shall continue to work on Netflix
on the drama series Outer Banks and
she's also busy cultivating her career
in live theater check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]